Welcome back everyone this will be my full dc
peacemaker episode 5 video there were a whole
bunch of easter eggs so we'll break it all down
if you're brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the episodes and careful
for spoilers if you have not seen the episode
yet we'll be talking about everything i'll just
start at the beginning of the episode and we'll
go through scene by scene talking about easter
eggs wtf moments and what they're setting up for
the finale starting with the episode title
monkey dory a play on the phrase hunky dory
old-timey slang for everything is okay but also
a reference to the gorilla the talking gorilla
i know everybody's wondering is that a gorilla
grodd easter egg is that who that's meant to be
it's them paying off charlie the gorilla the
easter egg from the earlier episode that escaped
from the zoo they turned it into a butterfly and
because of the strength multiplier that people
get when they become butterflies the sort of
stacking bonus the gorilla gets makes it crazy
powerful but you can't introduce a talking gorilla
into the dceu without thinking of gorilla grodd
so you could think of it as a subtle wink at grodd
but if they're gonna do grodd in the dceu actually
like full blown grodd it would probably be inside
one of the flash movies the actual opening scene
is peacemaker making himself a hangover drink the
next morning because he got so wasted him pouring
the alien honey into the jar for the butterfly is
his version of doing it another solid like he got
it high last night for free here's a freebie for
you now he's giving it its version of a hangover
drink eagerly leaves him another present of a
dead animal just like he did in episode 1 to make
him feel better he is a good boy the eagle clearly
cares about him like a more intelligent version of
a dog or a cat there are also some theories i have
after the end of the episode too because they said
this whole idea of that butterflies can be any
kind of animal too so they might have some huge
twists in the future early theory that eagerly
also winds up being a butterfly amanda waller
checks back in with leota pressuring her to plant
the copy of peacemaker's diary in his mobile home
which she does at the end of the episode and
everyone's still wondering why is amanda waller
doing that what's in the diary that she needed so
bad that she stole it copied it and wants to plan
a fake where he won't find it although it seems
like the detectives that are getting the warrant
will bust into his mobile home and they'll wind up
finding the diary so that might come back to bite
him in the ass without him even realizing it i
think the reason why amanda waller wants it hidden
inside his mobile home is so that he won't find
it and then realize that amanda waller stole his
journal the only thing that i can think of right
now that his diary might contain is information
about his father white dragon maybe amanda waller
wants his technology or is monitoring him for some
reason or she might just want his journal because
it could contain secrets that could link things
back to her so she's just trying to erase any kind
of paper trail leading back to her when murn gives
his briefing about the billionaire alan cooper
berg that name is actually an easter egg for a
real-life dc comics artist who's worked with neil
adams done a bunch of justice league firestorm
other dc comics in the past even some marvel x-men
comics just a whole bunch of stuff the pop singer
vandalia isn't meant to be a comic book character
but there is a wild storm character named vandalia
and wildstorm was kind of integrated into the dc
universe a while ago he claims that their death
a year ago in the timeline was the first known
case of butterfly parasites that puts it around
the same time the events of the suicide squad
movie were happening when they went to corto
maltese so you have to imagine amanda waller is
learning about the butterflies around the time
she's starting to deal with the starro problem i
think they also imply that the butterflies have
been on earth for much longer it's just that
that's the first time that they detected them
and since last year they said they've been finding
more and more butterflies and powerful important
figures all over the world because now they know
what to look for celebrities politicians powerful
people in all areas of modern culture love all the
jokes about john economos going way overboard with
his powerpoint tutorial animating the butterflies
going in people's butts like that's something that
he just did on his own they go through the butt
the butt is an orifice okay we'll call that the
butterflies pulling at thanos which definitely
takes you back one of my most fun things about
the whole avengers endgame rollout all the
interviews the russos and kevin feige did all
the marvel people was seeing them try to answer
thanos questions which they eventually did and it
was amazing what if ant-man went up thanos's butt
and just made himself bigger peacemaker implies
superman has a poop fetish because he's an alien
as if all aliens are like that and remember this
is inside the dc eu so he's talking about henry
cavill superman funny side note too if superman
actually focused he could hear peacemaker doing
him dirty like this all the way from metropolis on
the other side of the united states the joke about
him learning all these superman facts on google is
just a callback to the aquaman jokes from episode
one aquaman having sex with fish that he read on
social media the whole idea is that everything
he reads on social media like twitter he believes
no matter how outlandish it sounds he's just that
much of a summer child that he believes everything
he reads online is the truth they confirm the
glenn thai bottling company is the place where
the butterflies are making their honey-like food
source which they say scientifically doesn't
resemble any known substance on earth they also
imply that the actual source of the honey itself
is not the plant so that means the honey itself is
coming from somewhere else that they have to find
the fact the company was created in 1979 might be
an easter egg for a dc comics event or it could
just be someone's birthday usually dates
and numbers are easter eggs for something
the 1542 number on annie sterphausen's worker
badge is another reference to the green lantern
comics for sector 1542 it appeared during the kyle
rayner run it's just a planet named arose it's a
very strict religious based society but that's
about it there's been a bunch of green lantern
easter eggs in the series so far so they might
use the peacemaker series to help set up the green
lantern hbo series that's premiering next year
in 2023 then peacemaker goes on his most epic of
rants about all the celebrities that he can think
of that john economos could have put in prison
instead of his father and it just goes on and on
and on they even use the post credit scene for a
longer version of it optimus prime shipwreck cobra
commander the kids from riverdale and he did not
have to go that hard on the riverdale characters
noted peacemaker is not a fan of riverdale
vigilante lets us know he's a huge fargo fan and
reveals he didn't go through puberty till he was
in his mid-20s then peacemaker's father gives them
up to the detectives and they set up this whole
arc where amanda waller sends in another mercenary
to keep him in prison just further setting up
white dragon as a villain to go after peacemaker
and the team like as much as they have this plot
with the butterflies i think the big twist of
the series is that by the finale the biggest
battle that they fight will actually be peacemaker
versus his father or at least that'll be the most
impactful most emotional fight the big butterfly
payoff will probably be some cool deep cut from
the dc comics mythology but they've just done way
more to set up what's going on with peacemaker's
father in that conflict than they have with the
butterflies like we know way more about what's
going on with white dragon than the butterflies at
this point and they're only a couple episodes left
then when they're joking about how much of a bully
peacemaker is i love the way leota calls them out
for staring at dudes dogs way too much like
wait a minute you just stand around looking at
everyone's junk what then they reveal that someone
really high up in the government keeps blocking
all official police action in agencies against
butterfly related stuff confirming that people
in the upper levels of the us government are
butterflies themselves they'll probably confirm
who it is before the finale then they explain
that even amanda waller who runs task force x the
suicide squad program as a regular black ops group
like already it's super shady has to secretly
divert funds to them under the table under the
suicide squad table to avoid any further detection
so they're like a black ops group within a black
ops group like they're dealing with a situation
so shady that it has to be more secretive than
what happened with a regular suicide squad mission
to take care of starro as crazy as things got with
that there's also another sly reference to mern
being a butterfly again when peacemaker says it's
the five of them against an alien invasion and
harcourt has to remind him to include mern like no
no it's six of us because even though peacemaker
is the biggest monkey brain in there they keep
showing us moments where he just low-key has this
savant-like ability to detect things like he has
a really good radar for picking up clues like this
even if he doesn't completely realize it at the
time and even though he and john economos have
been going for each other's throats this whole
time they bond completely over this mutual love of
hair metal bands like hanoi rocks and their best
friends by the end of the episode like he's closer
to jonah con most by the end of the episode than
he is to vigilante they revealed john economos
is this huge stand of hanoi rocks even has one of
their songs tattooed on his arm and then the song
peacemaker plays in the car right after this is
that 11th street kids song that he has tattooed
on his arm that harcourt then uses the name for
their little group chat at the end of the episode
they introduced christopher hairdoll's lock
character you might remember him from the stargate
tv shows he's not playing summer from the comics
but in the dceu in the context of the show he's
just another mercenary working for amanda waller
who knows murn from their earlier days before
they both started working for amanda waller when
he mentions the jungles of niacire that's a dc
comics jungle region in northern africa featured
in the superman comics there was a village there
that was burned to the ground after this big
military conflict involving a religious group
attempting to convert the locals to their faith so
it's implied that murn and lock here were involved
in some kind of mass killing incident some sort of
genocidal event where they killed a ton of people
murn did say earlier that he was trying to atone
for his previous actions in his work for amanda
waller and then when he tells locke's character
that he's changed since those events in the
jungles he's also referencing becoming a butterfly
but right now it's not clear whether or not
mern's butterfly is one of the good butterflies
or a bad butterfly because it does seem like
there are different factions of butterflies like
why would a butterfly be trying to kill all the
other butterflies and get rid of them the whole
idea is that amanda waller is bringing in luck
to help mern keep white dragon in prison and from
messing their mission up so they plant him as the
new police chief he swaps the fingerprints but i
think that's only a stall white dragon inevitably
will get out of prison suit up in his white dragon
costume and then go after peacemaker and the team
when they roll into the factory notice that
peacemaker has official dove of peace symbols
on all of his guns this time meaning that he won't
have any kind of panic attacks or mental issues
killing any of the butterflies and he really does
rack up a body count like he enjoys every minute
he's in there what the hell is that it's a grenade
i tied to a russian tank shot why not just the
grenade grenade blows up like two people how many
people does this blow up i don't know i invented
it this morning i'm not sure what this srt138
license plate number is meant to be a reference to
it's not action comics or superman because those
issues don't have any connection to the plot of
the episode so if you think you know what this is
meant to be a reference to just write it below in
the comments he brings his x-ray vision helmet
so that he can see through the skulls and detect
who's a butterfly they also use this twist later
at the end of the episode when leota puts it on
discovering that murn is a butterfly and as you'd
expect pretty much everybody at the plant is a
butterfly but the way they explain the plant is
it is just there for bottling the honey fluid
they don't actually create the fluid there they'll
have to go find where it's coming from in a future
episode but they do pay off charlie the gorilla
from earlier in the series like i said the gorilla
who escaped from the zoo as i said you could
think of him as a gorilla grodd easter egg because
talking gorilla of course you would think of grodd
but he's not meant to literally be gorilla grodd
love the way they pay off the chainsaw joke with
john economos saves them by getting charlie in the
back with a chainsaw officially winning peacemaker
over if all the hanoi rocks didn't do it before
this then the whole thing with the team bonding
on the way back even though they play this like a
really positive moment the group's coming together
amelia harcourt takes the picture of them together
in the truck covered in blood and then calls it
the 11th street gang after the hanoi rock song
but the thing is is that now that there's evidence
linking them together so the actual picture might
wind up coming to bite them in the ass in the
future then back at their base when they're
talking about butterflies being any kind of life
form animals too like i said i think they'll
probably foreshadow a big animal butterfly twist
in the future worst case scenario would be eagerly
winds up being a butterfly but you can post all
your theories in the comments below what kind of
animal butterfly twist do you think we'll see in
the future leota uses drinks with peacemaker as an
excuse to plant that fake journal there's a kite
man easter egg which is kind of funny peacemaker
apprehending him earlier in his career kite man
is this obscure batman villain who most of you
have probably seen on the harley quinn animated
series did i just hear the wind say kite man
check out my apartment number it was a 66. oh god
you make this so hard hell yeah he's meant to be
the most ridiculous batman character ever and
that's the way they play him during that series
he calls his special drink a peace train it's gin
vermouth vinegar peppercorn maple syrup and yak
butter maybe james gunn will post the full recipe
for it online one of you can try it and leave
a comment with how it tastes because based on
their reactions it looks like it tastes terrible
yum she plants that fake journal and then
discovers mern as a butterfly using peacemaker's
x-ray helmet in the way they play this cliffhanger
they want you to think that murn is going to
kill her but clearly he is not like she's the
main character she'll be in all the episodes
early prediction the way they play this twist
the way he's looking at her is that they'll
use the payoff for the cliffhanger to reveal
the relationships between the different types
of butterflies like some of them are bad some
of them are good like why is murn a butterfly
wanting to get rid of all the other butterflies
it would only make sense if there are different
factions of butterfly and i think the big surprise
is that the butterflies themselves will not wind
up being the biggest villains it'll probably wind
up being peacemaker's father at least in a certain
context but like i said the post-credit scene is
just a longer version of peacemaker going on the
rant naming off celebrities to put in prison mario
super mario luigi yoshi the princess he names off
a bunch of fast food mascots burger king grimace
ronald mcdonald and i love the way they pay this
off where economos is like okay i agree all those
people could go to prison but not ariana grande
never her as if he stands her more than he stands
hanoi rocks if you haven't seen any of the behind
the scenes or seen james gunn talking about the
way they film these kinds of scenes is what he'll
do is he'll sit off of screen and just feed lines
to john cena so when john cena is ranting all
those celebrity names you have to picture james
gunn speaking to a microphone kind of giving him
all that dialogue on the fly if you spotted any
other easter eggs in the episode that i didn't
talk about in the video just write them below in
the comments i'll put a link for all my peacemaker
episodes in the description below too my full
peacemaker episode 6 video and star wars book of
boba fett episode video we'll post next week just
like normal make sure you have alerts enabled for
my channel so you don't miss those everyone click
here for my full book of boba fett episode 5 video
probably the best episode of the series so far and
click here for my new marvel secret invasion first
look video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!